we'll begin with this Muller we'll take
questions from members of the House
Judiciary and intelligence committees
now this is his first public testimony
on Russia's influence into the 2016
election his appearance before the
committee is expected to last five hours
and Muller will be pressed on his
findings including his decision not to
charge President Trump the testimony
will be closely watched by the public in
fact people started to line up early
this morning at the Capitol just to
catch a glimpse of the largely silent
investigator we have a team on this
story Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill
major Garrett and Jan Crawford are in
our Washington bureau and Paula Reid is
at the White House all of them are
standing by to cover every angle but we
begin with Nancy inside the hearing room
where molar will appear first Nancy what
can we expect
well Muller will be seated at the
witness table just behind me and this is
really going to be a tale of two
hearings Democrats will want Muller to
spell out potential acts of obstruction
by this president while Republicans are
going to press him on the origins of his
investigation the president already up
and tweeting about those origins this
morning and adding to all of the drama
is the fact that Muller himself threw a
curve ball to lawmakers with a
last-minute request to have one of his
top aides sworn in to the American
people were misled and now we have to
correct that record on the eve of
Muller's appearance Democrats worked in
one last prep session divvying up
questions to avoid repetition we just
want him to be able to walk the American
people through the multiple acts of
obstruction of justice by Donald Trump
Rhode Island's David Cicilline plans to
ask about one incident detailed in the
Muller report where President Trump
ordered a former aide corey lewandowski
to tell the Attorney General to limit
Muller's probe and you think that that
was a case of obstruction of justice
absolutely this is a case in which it's
very clear that the purpose of taking
that action was to prevent the Special
Counsel from continuing his
investigation the 74 year-old Muller hit
lawmakers with a late request Tuesday to
share today's hot seat with his deputy
Aaron Zeb Lee would you have an issue
with very much
one in he wasn't part of the witness
list Georgia Republican Doug Collins
sits on the Judiciary Committee which
denied Muller's request but will allow
Zeb Lee to advise Muller the
Intelligence Committee which goes second
today will let Zeb Lee testify alongside
his boss the move outraged President
Trump who called it a disgrace and very
unfair predicting his critics would come
up short today you have no collision
obstruction and yet it goes on and they
think this is helping them I personally
think it's hurting them but judiciary
chair Jerry Nadler said the main goal
today is to educate the public president
in the Attorney General have
systematically lied to the American
people that what was in that report I
know they've said no obstruction no
collusion he was totally exonerated
although those three statements are not
true between the two committees today
there are 60 lawmakers set to grill
Muller and if you do the math it's hard
to see how all of them are going to get
there five minutes the Republicans who
run the Senate have no plans to hold a
similar hearing with Muller as one of
them Republican John Kennedy of
Louisiana told us Tony this issue is as
dead as fried chicken we shall see about
that Nancy I know you'll be on this
force all day we'll see you in our
special coverage ahead thank you very
much